When it comes to the manufacturing and design of high-tech toilets,...
...there's no country in the world that surpasses Japan,...
...but now they've taken it to another level...
...and they've designed and installed the world's very first see-through toilet cubicle.
So, these newly installed cubicles are funded by the Nippon Foundation,...
...and although it's transparent and certainly catching a lot of attention,...
...there are a few sensible reasons behind it.
So, one of the main reasons is actually safety.
A lot of attacks that happen against women often happen in public bathrooms...
...in areas that are less lit and less populated.
The idea here is that the glass is actually transparent when it's not in use,...
...so they can see if someone is waiting inside.
It's a universally held opinion that public toilets are often gross...
...and rather grim places that you really only opted to use...
...if you had no other choice.
In a bid to change the status quo, the Nippon Foundation...